habilité vis-à-vis des pharmacies et des
patients la parole est à monsieur pierre
morel à l'huissier merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
le 13 novembre 2013
à l'appel du syndicat alliance cinq
mille policiers avaient manifesté
il y a trois ans un an plus tard le
trésor en 2014
8500 policiers ont défilé à paris pour
je cite dénoncer leurs conditions de
travail et le mal-être dans la police il
y a deux ans en octobre 2015 une autre
manifestation était organisée dans
l'événement déclencheur était la
fusillade au cours de laquelle un
policier de la bac a été grièvement
blessé l'auteur des coups de feu était
un détenu ensuite qui n'avait pas
réintégré sa prison après une
autorisation de sortie il ya simplement
un an
enfin en juin 2016 lors d'une cérémonie
d'hommage au couple de policiers
assassinés à magnanville un policier a
refusé de serrer la main au président de
la république monsieur le prémisse de
vous et vous devez vous en souvenir
personnellement vous y était il y a
simplement cinq mois si je reprends ses
différents événements c'est vous faire
comprendre que les manifestations
actuelles sont l'expression d'un mal qui
couve depuis plusieurs années les
policiers sont exaspérés et fatigués ils
sont asphyxiés en termes de procédures
et les réponses pénales ne sont plus
adaptés des voyous sont en liberté
il ya aussi une volant de violences
accrues et le sentiment que les
délinquants n'ont plus peur de leur
police certains dénoncent le fait qu'ils
ne sont plus que deux et non 3 dans les
véhicules de service
d'autres parlent de zones de non-droit
dans certains quartiers de réseaux
connus et non démantelé plus que des
revendications catégorielles
ce sont les conditions mêmes de
l'exercice de leur métier qu'ils
dénoncent
et nous ne pouvons qu'être sensible au
regard de leur dévouement et je pense
aussi aux pompiers aux policiers
municipaux et aux gendarmes
aujourd'hui c'est au tour du présent
république de recevoir les représentants
des policiers
ma question est simple allez vous enfin
les entendre la parole est à monsieur
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur
monsieur le député je leur dis vraiment
avec beaucoup de sincérité de gravité si
comme c'est votre cas je vous connais
personnellement respecte les policiers
on leur doit la vérité et on ne peut pas
être devant la représentation nationale
je sais qu'il ya des échéances
électorales
elle nous concerne tous en indiquant en
question après question qu'il y aurait
une espèce d'âge d'or à l'occasion
duquel vous le savez beaucoup d'emplois
ont été supprimés une espèce
d'incapacité de ce gouvernement à
répondre aux questions qui sont posées
et pour connaître comme le premier
ministre a été mise de l'intérieur bien
les policiers je sais qu'ils attendent
de nous parce qu'ils sont en souffrance
de la dignité de la vérité et pas des
outrances et pas des vociférations et je
vous rappeler quand même je me permets
de vous le dire qu'au cours des derniers
jours il y à un certain nombre de
candidats aux primaires qui sont
déplacés dans les commissariats monsieur
le candidat aux primaires député de
l'eure monsieur bruno le maire s'est
déplacé dans les commissariats pour
indiquer qu on avait supprimé 13 mille
emplois sous monsieur fillon monsieur
sarkozy et qu'il regrettait monsieur
juppé a regretté la même chose en
indiquant qu'on avait grand tort de le
faire donc je pense que sur ce sujet là
il faudrait être moins dans la
confrontation
- dans l'embarqué nisation est davantage
dans le respect la première chose sur
laquelle je voudrais insister c'est que
nous avons créé près de 9000 emplois que
nous avons augmenté de 15% les moyens de
la police et que tout à l'heure
autour du président de la république
après avoir écouté longuement les
organisations syndicales nous allons
ensemble annoncé un ensemble de mesures
qui s'inscrivent dans la continuité de
ce que nous avons déjà fait et qui sont
destinés à répondre très précisément à
autant de sujets différents que la
légitime défense
l'anonymisation des policiers les
matériels supplémentaires dont ils ont
besoin donc j'appelle à sur ce sujet
comme sur d'autres à ce que nous soyons
dans la dignité et dans la vérité